I'm here outside the front of Gander
welding works and engineering and you
guessed it I'm in Gander and it's a warm
day out here but my gosh can this
business turn some work in they do all
the work for about 100 km there's no
other Workshop within KU this place so
they have everything from the councils
the um uron Power
suppliers any of the major players but
most of their work comes from the Citrus
industry and the farms around the area
and this place has got a mountain of
Machinery there's absolutely everything
that you could look for in regards to
welding and fabricating these guys will
build everything as you can see from
here you've got tractor slashers uh pump
rebuilds they do a massive amount of
hydraulics a lot of particularly um
specialized ladders for the Citrus
industry that is transported overseas
and all the way up to tul it's a massive
business so give me a call if you're
interested